l'école face à la crise sanitaire et
pour cela j'accueille sur ce plateau est
l'un des spécialistes de cette question
de l'école ici au sénat bonjour max
brisson merci beaucoup de nous rejoindre
ce matin vous êtes sénateur des pyrénées
atlantiques vous êtes l'un des
spécialistes de ces questions vous avez
d'ailleurs interpellé jean-michel
blanquer récemment sur ce sujet avant de
vous entendre on va regarder ce
reportage marion delpech s'est rendu à
guyancourt dans les yvelines voir
comment les enseignants les parents
d'élèves mais aussi le maire tout ce
monde fait face au casse-tête du
protocole sanitaire on regarde ce
reportage
dans ce groupe scolaire des yvelines la
valse des protocoles sanitaires a
parfois entraîné des situations
chaotiques sur ces 15 derniers jours
toutes les classes ont fermé au moins
une fois c'est toute l'organisation qui
est chamboulée y compris le temps
éducatif comme le souligne le directeur
du périscolaire là aujourd'hui c'est
plus de l'organisationnel c'est d'être
sûr qu'on colle vraiment à ce protocole
malgré tout on fait en sorte quand même
de faire notre métier d'accueillir les
enfants dans les meilleures conditions
possibles on est obligé de mettre en
place un système où les enfants on ne
peut pas les bras c'est les enfants
suivent un encadrant alors qu'avant les
enfants choisissaient les activités dans
lequel il voulait le temps de la
restauration par exemple c'était
vraiment une soupape pour eux ils
pouvaient pas être au contact de plus
grand de plus petits avaient un vrai
échange est aujourd'hui avec ce
protocole malheureusement on ne peut
plus pousser notre pédagogie on ne peut
plus faire notre travail comme on le
faisait avant au-delà des questions de
logistique de mise en place des
protocoles sanitaires successifs le
phénomène des enseignants malades non
remplacés s'est amplifiée avec la crise
sanitaire les parents d'élèves doivent
désormais composer avec les nombreuses
absences des professeurs on perd un peu
le sens là en haut et on arrive à
quasiment deux ans de crise les parents
sont vraiment inquiets
aujourd'hui la gestion logistique au
jour le jour avec les employeurs
certains parents les familles
monoparentales surtout peut se trouver
en grande difficulté vis-à-vis de leur
employeur parce que tout le monde ne
peut pas télé travailler et on
s'inquiète aussi effectivement pour la
suite de savoir si les moyens vont
vraiment être mis sur la table pour
permettre à nos enfants d'avoir une
scolarité épanouie et puis de d'être
bien dans leurs baskets et les citoyens
de demain parce que c'est vraiment ça
dont il est question pour le maire de la
ville le maître mot a été l'adaptation
de tous parents enseignants mais
également les professionnels du
périscolaire l'édile fait partie des 37
mer des yvelines qui ont écrit au
premier ministre pour un allègement du
protocole sanitaire ce gouvernement n'a
pas trouvé intéressant ou pertinent en
tout cas de consulter les élus de
terrain vous faites référence à ce texte
que j'ai signé avec de nombreux autres
maires du département des yvelines
encore une fois d'une manière totalement
transparente isana c'est à dire qu' il
n'y a pas une volonté politique
politicienne de mettre en difficulté ce
gouvernement c'est simplement de
rappeler les éléments réels de terrain
voilà et et vous vous mentionner ces
annonces tardives dont on a l'habitude
depuis deux ans en soyons très clairs on
a toujours dû subir à l'arrivée de
textes les annonces dans les médias et
dernièrement j'ai envie de dire la
cerise sur le gâteau le fait d'annoncer
dans des médias de payants et donc non
accessibles à tout un chacun le premier
ministre a indiqué jeudi envisager un
allègement du protocole dans les écoles
au retour des vacances de février ces
annonces pourraient concerner le port du
masque et les tests à réaliser plusieurs
syndicats enseignants appellent à
poursuivre le mouvement lors de la grève
interprofessionnel sur les salaires et
l'emploi prévue jeudi prochain mais sont
d'abord votre réaction à ce reportage on
est en jeu enseignants parents d'élèves
mère alors avec des problématiques
certes différentes mais un point commun
ils ont une faculté à faire face à ce
protocole sanitaire votre reportage dit
tout je voudrais d'abord évacué deux
éléments d'abord c'est difficile dont
acte
joseph blatter gère une gestion
difficile deuxièmement on passe très
vite sur les épisodes rocambolesques et
triste de la semaine de rentrée avec un
protocole sorti la veille modifié deux
jours après tre transformé trois jours
du jour après annulé trois jours
suivants et finalement le premier
ministre qui siffle la fin de la
récréation on laisse tomber ces deux
éléments même si pour les parents ils
ont été très perturbateurs comme c'est
dit dans votre reportage était ce qu'il
reste au fond c'est un révélateur le
protocole c'est révélateur comme le dit
très bien le maire de système très
centralisé très verticale l'éducation
nationale est le seul ministère en
europe occidentale d'un million deux
cent mille fonctionnaires
comment voulez vous que ça marche dans
une société moderne dans une société en
réseau dans une société horizontale nous
sommes le seul pays à avoir conservé un
système éducatif hyper centralisé et
finalement la crise de l'aco vide est le
révélateur de cela à force de tout
décider la rue de grenelle j'ai dit à la
hausse et n'a finalement que le banquier
risme était une forme d'autoritarisme
esseulé jarmusch et blanc claire décide
dans son cabinet au ministère au 110 rue
de grenelle sans jamais faire confiance
ni aux équipes éducatives ni aux chiens
d'établissement ni au merle bleu mer le
dis très très bien pour ce qu il s est
le révélateur pas été consultés c'est le
révélateur d'une absence de confiance de
sa certitude qu'à jean michel blanquer
d'avoir raison tout seul avec son
cabinet on vient on le verra petit tout
à l'heure avec le recteur de paris à
nouveau une cour autour du ministre une
certitude qu'il a raison et la volonté
toujours de passer au forceps sur
l'acquis sanitaires comme sur beaucoup
d'autres domaines du ce de l'ensemble du
système éducatif tokuda vaudra romain
premier ministre de l'éducation
nationale qui s'est autant isolé de
l'ensemble des communes hôtes de la
communauté éducative il en est conscient
selon vous nous interpeller vous auquel
je ne les contenants je pense qu ils
crient à l'injustice parce qu'ils
pensent qu'ils avaient raison est encore
regarde y'a une seule question qui se
pose au delà de la crise sanitaire
est-ce que l'école va mieux aujourd'hui
par rapport à 2007 je ne pense pas sur
toutes les annonces de jean michel
larqué qui était présenté comme le
ministre de droite le mystère nice hier
le ministre compétent est-ce que sur la
transmission des savoirs est-ce que ce
soit des classements internationaux
est-ce que sur l'autonomie des
établissements est-ce que sur
l'orientation professionnelle ou tendent
annonce jean michel blanquer en 2017 on
a une amie récents griot tanoh il y a
une raison à cela il n'a pas fait ce
qu'il vous m'avez dit qu'il ferait ce
comme le président macro candidat avait
dit qu'il ferait l'autonomie des
établissements jamais et c'est pas que
la jamais regardé ce que dit la cour des
comptes jamais on n'a autant mis
l'établissement en coupe réglée de
circulaires et de directives comment
voulez-vous cliché interdit seulement
qui croule sous les directives est envie
de faire par eux-mêmes on va faire
réagir piagge interjette moi ce que vous
avez dit notamment sur le blanc charisme
c'est un autoritarisme
je pense qu'il l'a il va avoir cumulé
pas mal de deux médailles effectivement
monsieur blanc caire parce qu'il est
sans doute le miz l'éducation nationale
qui aura été le plus long de l'histoire
peut-être de la vème république en tout
cas il a failli s'il fait tout le
quinquennat mais c'est aussi sans doute
ce qui va le rattraper c'est à dire
qu'on sent aujourd'hui une forme de
lassitude et cette lassitude et ses
autres ss se transmet par ray dans la
pratique de l'exercice du pouvoir en
entend l'ensemble des syndicats
d'enseignants mais aussi les fédérations
de parents d'élèves mais plus largement
la communauté éducative dire que ils
sont face à un mur ils n'ont pas eu de
dialogue pendant ce quinquennat avec
monsieur blanc caire est certes monsieur
blanca vous l'avez dit est un technicien
c'est vrai qu'il est celui qui connaît
sans doute le mieux peut-être la machine
de l'éducation nationale et il est un
ancien haut fonctionnaire de l'éducation
nationale il a eu beaucoup de postes
mais il est aussi un théoricien de
l'éducation d'assurer en ce sens il a
fait beaucoup de mal c'est à dire que
aujourd'hui vous le disiez peut-être
qu'il y ait une centralisation peut-être
trop importante mais là où je serai sans
doute pas d'accord avec vous c'est que
vous voulez une autonomie peut-être des
établissements scolaires ce que je crois
être compliqué parce que on est dans un
système républicain où on doit l'état
doit une égalité d'accès à l'école pour
tous avec les mêmes moyens et donc je
pense que le système avec les académies
peut-être que les académies de voir plus
de moyens et plus de pouvoirs pour faire
en sorte que les établissements
fonctionnent mieux et notamment en
période de crise et que ce soit moi le
problème du ministre de l'éducation
nationale mais plus généralement moi je
crois que le monsieur blanquart fait
aujourd'hui face à une crise importante
parce que cinq ans de blanc charisme ça
va avoir marqué l'histoire de la vème
république et je pense que les écoles
publiques en l'occurrence parce que
c'est l'école privée qui a été largement
priorisés dans le cadre de ce
quinquennat on aura beaucoup pâti et ce
système centralisé il provoque de proue
puissante et inégalités il ya un
égalitarisme de discours il ya une
réalité de puissantes inégalités et ce
qui est grave c'est comment la jeunesse
en lui faisant croire que par la
centralisation on a un système
centralisé et je crois que de tous les
péchés du monde le plus grave c'est de
mentir à la jeunesse ce système
égalitaire n'existe pas dans la réalité
vous final discours égalitaire tout en
misant agissements elle aimait aussi en
compétition
nous verrons bien les modalités ne
critiquons pas avant que ça se fasse
aujourd'hui au aujourd'hui on peut
perdre aux stars les anniversaires
aujourd'hui aujourd'hui on peut faire un
constat ensemble c'est que les notre
système éducatif est profondément
inégalitaire et d'assurer que l'aumône
en disant que c'est un système
égalitaire et que les systèmes
décentralisés autour de nous alors qu'il
était quasiment tout centralisé il y
avait trente ou quarante ans les
systèmes décentralisés au plus tôt
réduit les inégalités dont on s'obstine
à considérer que le système centralisé
le meilleur parce qu'on le parce qu'on
est dans l'idéologie on dit dans le
discours égalitaire alors que la réalité
est totalement totalement différente on
continue d'imaginer qu'il faut ni volé
au nom de l'égalité alors que je pense
qu'il faut libérer qu'il faut donner
confiance en voudrions faire confirmer
ce maquereau qui dit justement lui veut
d'ailleurs
moi même où ce maquereau dans ce
quinquennat a fait le contraire de ce
qu'il dit je pense qu'on va voir sur
l'éducation tous beaucoup de sujets un
candidat qui va dire le contact ce qu'il
a fait jamais l'autonomie des
établissements est aussi rogné sous ce
quinquennat jamie a eu autant de
circulaire c'est pas moi qui le dit
c'est la cour des comptes 2 % des
décisions des collèges et des lycées
sont prises en autonomie 2% et se nomme
s'est jamais produit c'est une absence
de confiance il faut faire confiance aux
équipes éducatives pour un s'adapter aux
réalités des publics elles reçoivent on
va revenir sur l'un des points de ce
reportage sur les écoles face à la crise
nous le débat passionnant c'est juste un
petit peu éloigné du sujet sur la aussi
peut-être le discours vous allez nous
dire entre la différence entre le
discours et la réalité le gouvernement
vante les écoles ouvertes il dit mais
non
on a gardé les écoles ouvertes c'est un
point positif on le voit dans le
reportage sur les quinze derniers jours
toutes les classes ont fermé au moins
une fois est-ce que là aussi il ya une
différence entre le discours du
gouvernement et la réalité dans les
écoles je pense que le confinement a été
une alerte aussi l'école est utile le
métier de professeur de métier difficile
donc moi je ne fais pas le reproche au
gouvernement d'avoir cherché à maintenir
les écoles ouvertes c'est un objectif
tout à fait louable le reproche que je
lis fait je les ai déjà dit je le répète
tout en disant clairement moi je serais
pas de démagogie la gestion de la crise
sanitaire d'une gestion difficile mais
je pense qu'une approche beaucoup plus
proche des établissements permettant de
bien mesurer on a normalement des chefs
d'établissement qui sont en
responsabilité
on a des mères ou des présidents de
conseils départementaux qui sont en
responsabilité je pense qu'on aurait pu
avoir une approche beaucoup plus fine
que des protocoles extrêmement complexe
et que ça montre une autre at it dans
lequel tout le monde est perdu
le gouvernement dit beaucoup on a laissé
les écolos vers pourvoi dans la réalité
c'est un peu compliqué quand même c'est
sûr que le variant au micron a mis en
difficulté plein de secteurs de la
société les hôpitaux mais des écoles etc
les entreprises dont il ya une pression
qui est accrue alors je crois que le
gouvernement a lui-même reconnu que sur
l' annonce du protocole le effectivement
dans la presse payante et c'est à la
veille de la rentrée il y avait une
marge de progression évidente ils l'ont
dit et il ya un autre aménagement ou un
allègement même qui est prévue après les
vacances scolaires d'affairé de février
certes tout n'a pas été bien je pense
dans la non st
du protocole d'entente et dans la
concertation après ces invariants
camille en désordre toute la société
c'est le cas en france les cas dans
d'autres pays donc il faut faire avec
effectivement sur l'ouverture des écoles
certains dans l'opposition on
préconisait de les fermer
c'est sûr que c'était une décision ou au
moins il y avait moins de débats et -
des organisations les choses auraient
été plus nette donc c'est un débat qui
est compliqué c'est un débat qui est
compliquée et je pense que la mesure des
choses c'est d'attendre effectivement
que la vague passe et lloris pour rien
comprenez
on était la sortie des vacances
scolaires n'aurait pu les prolonger sans
précédent des gars est ce que ce n'est
pas le seul à dire oui c'est ce que toi
tu vas les caisses mais cela dit un
protocole aussi complexe il peut pas
s'appliquer voilà sans doute parce que
ce qu'on attendait du gouvernement ce
qu'on a dit jean michel blanquer c'est
un protocole simple et beaucoup de
liberté sur le terrain pour les élus
locaux et pour les responsables des
établissements et vous avez tenu les 30
secondes son parfait merci dans ce débat
passionnant
[Musique]